I want to play this video for you this
is Canadian conservative party leader
and I know I can do this
Pierre po po I think I got it I think
that's his name po Le anyway he's a
Canadian conservative party leader and
he's gone viral with um for a positive
reason we don't see it's it's it's
pretty uncommon that we see a viral
video out of Canada that's going viral
for positive reasons but in this case uh
that's what happened here he is in an
exchange with uh some local media flak
and I think the way that he handles this
is pretty brilliant watch
this um on the on the topic I mean in
terms of your sort of strategy currently
you're obviously taking the populist uh
pathway um what does that
mean well appealing appealing to
people's uh more emotional levels I
would guess um I mean certainly
certainly you certainly you tap
certainly you tap very strong
ideological language quite frequently
like
what uh left wing you know this and that
right wing you know I mean it's that
that type of talk about I never really
talk about left or right anyways I don't
really believe in that okay a lot of
people would would say that you're
simply taking a page out of the Donald
Trump uh like which people would say
that well I'm sure a great many
Canadians but like
who I don't know who but well you're the
one who asked the question so how you
must know somebody
okay I'm I'm sure there's some out there
but anyways the point of this the point
of this question is I mean why should
why should Canadians trust you with
their vote
given you know not not just the sort of
ideological inclination in terms of
taking the page of Donald Trump's book
but what are you talking about what page
what page can you give me a page give me
the page you keep saying in terms in
terms of turn turning things quite
dramatically in terms of of Trudeau and
and the left wing and all of this I mean
you you you make quite a you know it's
it's quite a play that you make on it so
I'm I'm not sure I don't I don't know
what your question is then forget that
why should Canadians trust you with
their vote Common Sense common sense for
for a change we're going to make Common
Sense common in this country we don't
have any common sense in the current
government you know the guy prints $600
billion grows our money supply by
32% in 3 years that's growing the money
eight times faster than the economy no
wonder we have the worst inflation in
four
decades I'm going to cap spending cut
waste so that we can balance the budget
and bring down inflation and interest
rates you'll want to be able to pay your
mortgage again you want to be able to
afford rent then you have to vote for
Pierre PV because I'm the only one with
a common sense plan that will bring back
the buying power of your paycheck pev I
think is how I pronounced it I'm going
to go with my pronunciation anyway that
was uh that that was very well done and
uh it's it's sort of unfortunate that we
have to be so impressed with that
exchange not because it was not
impressive but because uh this is
how you this is how every conservative
politician and every conservative in
general should respond in these kinds of
situations um and this this is what the
media does right they'll they ask you a
question uh but it's not it's not it's
not a question the question is always
it's always loaded and they always build
it from a false premise and so they do
exactly what this guy did where they say
well this is who you are and this is
what you believe and it's totally
false and then and so therefore here's
my
question well most conservatives what we
seen historically is that they'll let
him get away with the false premise and
then they'll just launch off into some
speech you know uh answering or not
answering the
question but he's not going to let him
get away with it so so and you don't
have to do much it's not you don't have
to the other thing he's not doing is
he's not arguing against the false
premise he's not because then he's on
the defensive this is what he did that
was
uh that was quite quite
skillful is he's exposing the false
premise but he's not arguing against it
because if you argue against it then
then you're on the defensive it looks
like you are like you're guilty like you
have something a reason to defend
yourself all he's doing is just asking
well where'd you get that from
you know as
as as I've we've talked about plenty of
times these are most some of the most
powerful questions that you can ask
someone one is what do you mean by
that and we've seen that with a what is
a woman question just you say you're a
woman what do you mean by that simple
question it's a very fair question it's
not a gotcha question what do you mean
by that what do you mean by that and
where did you get
that why why are you saying that what do
you mean by that where did you get that
from who told you that why are you
saying that these these kinds of the the
most basic sorts of questions you could
possibly ask and what you find is that
these people cannot answer them people
always say happy dog happy life well if
that's really the case you need to be uh
giving your dog rough greens
naturopathic Dr Dennis black the founder
of rough greens is focused on improving
the health of every dog in America
before I started feeding my dog Ruff
greens I had no idea that dog food is
dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green well
let rough greens bring your dogs food
back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all of the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath Boost energy levels and so much
more uh we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident that Ru greens
will improve your dog's health he's
offering my listeners a free jump start
trial bag so your dog can try it a free
jump start trial bag can be at your door
in just a few business days go to Ru
greens.com mat or call 844 ru700 it's
rofg greens.com mat or call 844 Ru 700
today because this guy he's starting
from a false
premise well you're fascist you're this
of that you're a radical uh he he
doesn't even know where he got it this
is just uh this is is an impression that
this is something that he's absorbed
right he's absorbed it from the
atmosphere he has no idea where he got
it and so if you ask these basic
questions where did you get that from
what do you mean by that why are you
saying
that it all starts to fall apart and
break
down with almost no effort on PR's
part eating the apples a nice touch
usually I'm very much against people uh
eating while speaking or eating in
public at all where I have to see it
eating on camera but in this case it was
a nice touch because it it helped it you
know just had helped with this kind of
casual Vibe where he was totally
unbothered uh like politicians
Republican politicians in this country
should should take note hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there